spirituális alapok, amiben hiszünk.
Tanúi lehettünk Isten egy gyönyörű
csodájának. Különböző hátterű és
különböző felekezetekhez tartozó
hívőkként szervezetünkben anélkül
voltunk képesek növekedni és szolgálni
Isten királyságát, hogy dogmatikai
vitákba bonyolodtunk volna. Tragikus
módon a hívők történelmében hosszú
múltja van annak, hogy a lényegtelen
dolgokat a lényegesek szintjére emelték.
Bár elismerjük, hogy vannak a hitnek
olyan pillérei, amelyek nem tűrnek
kompromisszumot, mert Jézus Krisztus
központi üzenetei, de ezek ritkán
okozzák az egyház megosztottságát. A
kérdés, amit a mi nemzedékünknek fel
kell tennie, nem érdemes-e az egység
érdekében inkább feláldozni a tökéletes
véleményünket egy-egy bibliai kérdésben,
és inkább irgalmat mutatni egy másik
testvér iránt Krisztusban?
Lásd a válaszért a rómaiakhoz írt levél
14. fejezetét. Az egységünk erősítése és
a vitás kérdések miatti veszekedések
elkerülése érdekében szeretnénk
meghatározni a Bedenbo Companies
szervezetében, hogy melyek azok az
alapvető hitelvek, amelyekben hiszünk.
Ez segít minket abban, hogy az
evangélium középpontjában álló közös
alapokra összpontosítsunk, és
hatékonyabban védekezzünk a Sátán
közvetlen támadásaival szemben, amelyek
kikezdhetik-e királyság egységét.
Egyetlen igaz forrásban hiszünk. Isten
igéjében. Elfogadtunk egy két részből
álló hitrendszert. Az egyik részt
kifejezi a zárt kéz, alapvető dolgok. A
másikat a nyitott kéz, nem alapvető
dolgok. A zárt kézben lévő hitelvekért
érdemes meghalni. Ezek kevesen vannak,
de szívünkön viseljük őket, és
mindannyian osztozunk bennük. A nyitott
kézben lévő hitelvek száma ehhez képest
sok. És bár támogatjuk, hogy
tiszteletteljesen vitassuk meg ezeket,
de nem osztjuk őket mindannyian.
Határozottan ellenállunk annak a
megosztó késztetésnek, hogy a nyitott
kézből a zárt kézbe helyezzünk át
hitelveket. Ennek megfelelően a zárt
kézben lévő hitelvek képezik az alapját
munkánk teológiájának és szervezetünk
céljának. Hitünk lényege. A Biblia, az Ó
és új Testamentum 66 könyve, Istenletet
szent könyve. Elmeséli Isten üdvözítő
történetét, tanításai tekintélyt
követelnek a hívők életében. A hit és
élet legfőbb és végső tekintélye.
Timóteushoz írt második levél, harmadik
fejezet 14-től 17. versig. Csak egy igaz
Isten van.
Mózes ötödik könyve hatodik fejezet
negyedik vers. Isten Atya, Fiú és
Szentlélek. Máté evangéliuma 28. fejezet
19. vers. Isten teremtette a világot.
Mózes első könyve, első fejezet, első
vers. A világ bűnkövetkezményeként
elbukott. Rómaiakhoz írt levél, harmadik
fejezet 23. vers. Az Atya elküldte a
fiút a világba. János evangéliuma első
fejezet 14. vers. A fiú Jézus Krisztus
élt, prédikált, tanított, szeretett,
gyógyított, meghalt és feltámadt a
halálból, hogy megbékélést hozzon
Istennel.
Korintusiakhoz írt második levél, ötödik
fejezet 17-től 19. vers. Az üdvösség
egyedül Jézus Krisztusban van. János
evangéliuma 14. fejezet hatod. Vers:
Hiszük a Szentlélek aktív munkáját a
hívők életében és általuk.
János evangéliuma 16. fejezet 13. vers.
A hívők közössége Istent imádja, az
evangéliumot hirdeti, és Krisztus
rendelkezéseit betartja. Máté
evangéliuma 28. fejezet 16-tól 20.
versig. Jézus Krisztus vissza fog térni.
Apostolok cselekedetei. Első fejezet 11.
vers. Ezek azok az alapvető igazságok,
amelyeket vezetőkként egységesen
vallunk. Tudatosan ellenállunk a
megosztottságnak az olyan kérdésekben,
amelyek nyitott kezet kívánnak, mert
tudjuk, hogy a széthúzás aláássa a
kiengesztelődés evangéliumát.
Ezzel szemben a hívők spirituális
egysége erősíti a tanúságtételüket.